let's take a look at a so-called lawyer
apparently trying to defend and
represent her client I'm going to play
some videos for you of Donald Trump
lawyer Alina Hapa Alina Haba doesn't
know what's going on apparently because
she's going back to this old idea that
the FBI might have planted evidence at
Mar-A-Lago now I know you must be saying
David we're like weeks into this thing
we got beyond that Trump said yes he had
the documents but he Declassified them
telepathically potentially why are they
going back to the evidence might have
been planted it's because it's just a
circle of nonsense there were no
documents they were there but planted by
the FBI they were there because Trump
Declassified them and wanted them for
his Library slash Memoirs slash to read
but they weren't actually there because
the FBI planted it's just a circle it
just it's like a Mobius strip of
absurdity here is Alina Haba take a
listen to this well do you have evidence
that the FBI might have uh planted
planted something anything at Mar-A-Lago
seven weeks ago
you know what we know and I'm not going
to speak into details because because
you don't have any evidence even the
initial do you have evidence you know
what we know and I'm not going to speak
about details the answer is you have no
evidence that anything was planted it
would obviously be confidential and go
to the defense the case
um the attorney's handling it which I am
not but
as I have said on the show before
um I think the concern is that we have
recordings of these agents going in and
then we were not permitted to watch the
agents we see agents go in we see Agents
come out and we just don't know what of
what they took out was actually brought
in by them but do you have any evidence
but no no evidence but we just we saw
them go in and we saw them come out
Mar-A-Lago go into his office space for
instance or his home his bedroom or
melania's closet and that is incredibly
concerning another thing is they came in
with equipment with bags so you never
know unfortunately the client they
brought bags right that weren't
politically has led us to believe that
we can't really uh be sure that they're
following the rule of law at any point
and that's the most concerning thing I
think for all Americans right now and
understand the wishy-washy language we
don't know what they did in there we
don't know whether they're following the
rule of law do you it's the same thing
with the voter fraud stuff do you have
specific evidence to suggest a belief X
rather than we've not been able to rule
X out but but do you do you have any
evidence of X what leads you to believe
that Trump might have actually won
Georgia well listen we just don't know
who won there's irregularities and we
don't know who won and it's always good
do you have a reason to believe that
Trump specifically got more votes than
Biden in Georgia we don't know what
we're calling for is a full investigate
well but we've an investigation has been
done it's the exact same thing here do
you have evidence we don't know what
went on the FBI brought equipment and
they weren't on camera during the search
in Trump's office ah okay uh asked what
Donald Trump is doing now I guess she
says Trump's handling the investigation
by playing golf uh but at some point
Elena this has got to take a toll on
just somebody's psyche uh all these
lawsuits all these jurisdictions uh
how's he doing
I hate
first everybody 's trouble but you know
they they and when I say everybody I
mean the DNC the left
uh attackers but I can tell you I was
with him a couple days ago he is his
usual self he is in great spirits he is
you know out there working he is on the
golf course he is doing what he would
normally do the framing is like he's a
victim is he still in good spirits
despite this horrible thing that's being
done to him folks this is a guy being
investigated as a possible Criminal and
um quite honestly really optimistic for
the midterm elections and optimistic for
the country's future post Biden regime
right
um and I think that's what makes a
leader you can't get down when the
country is failing and you're under
siege U.S so anyway you might be
wondering why would a lawyer do this
this lawyer Alina Haba who's been
increasingly uh present in media why
would why would just a lawyer take this
as a job you have to understand she's
primarily like a political actor and if
you look at her Instagram you actually
see she calls herself a patriot and a
litigator with the American flags her
pictures are with Trump her going to
Mar-A-Lago and uh posting propaganda
about Trump posting pictures with Trump
posting a picture at one point with I'm
not even going to show it but like with
her kid her kids wearing a trump hat
this is primarily an individual acting
as a political actor not as a lawyer and
she actually said I'm not one of the
people representing Trump in the legal
proceedings here she's representing
Trump on television and it's absolutely
and completely pathetic something in
your home that you use every day
contributes to deforestation and climate
change and that's toilet paper in the
U.S alone over 30 million trees each
year are required to meet toilet paper
demands contributing to deforestation
soil erosion devastating loss of
biodiversity our sponsor real paper
makes sustainable toilet paper that is
100 made from bamboo a bamboo stock
keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below